[Music]
let's talk to rosie in court elaine
what's up rosie
hi how are you
oh i'm good how about you i'm good you
are on the show
all right all right so what's up how can
i help
so um
my husband i decided to uh
that i should stay home with our
five-year-old
and i've been doing that since june and
i feel like i stuck at it like i feel
like a failure
and that's what i want to talk about
well thanks for that softball appreciate
that rosie
so why did y'all
y'all the way you announced that
the way you told me that was that your
husband wanted you to stay at home and
you all talked about it and now you're
staying at home am i wrong there
um
yeah we decided together
who's ideal without i i think it was my
idea okay all right the way you
presented that sunday i usually have the
ideas
yes okay
so
um
why did you want to stay home
um
well
i want to stay home because um
i used to be able to take my son to work
with me
when i worked in child care
and when
that business was closing um
there just didn't seem like
being in the business we knew that there
was no one that we would trust with our
son
okay yes
so you don't trust anybody with your son
and so
you want to stay at home and be with him
do you like being around him
yeah mostly okay
and so here's the death spiral i just
hear professional woman after
professional woman after young mother
get involved in
there is no way to win
and if you're at work you should be at
home oh my gosh you just work and leave
your kid with somebody all day
and then if you're at home
it is
i don't like my kid all the time and as
soon as i have that thought like oh my
gosh if you wipe your own butt crack
then i feel guilty that i even said that
because this is my baby and i'm a
terrible mom
or if i just love wiping butt cracks all
day people are like are you serious you
just stay at home like what else what
are you contributing
like your husband just earns all the
like seriously you know
there's this
never-ending cycle of guilt
do you experience any of that
um
not really that mostly like
um
i thought that i i think i should be
doing better at
um keeping the house clean like it's
just always a mess and it seems like if
i'm home all day
it should be clean like that was my
expectation was so you know when i was
working 12 hours a day it was like i
have no time to clean the house whose
story is that i'm home all day is it
your story or your husband's story
mine okay then so i'm just gonna ask you
simple questions so then
why don't you clean the house
um
i
don't know like sometimes it seems like
sometimes it seems like we run out of
time like we're not just home all day
like we we go places and then by the
time we get home it's like
time to eat dinner and then
after all that stuff is done in bedtime
then it's just
and i get tired yeah
so i don't know that's why i ask myself
is like why am i not getting this done
like
i should be able to do it
have you made a
so much here
you're living in some pretty hard
pictures that you've created for
yourself you've drew drawn for yourself
you have a picture of what stay-at-home
motherhood should look like
and your picture isn't real
it seems like it for the people i know
in their curated social media worlds
or like i go to their house and it's
clean well maybe
and yeah there's two hands one is you've
created a myth you are not them you are
you
and you're trying to live their story
and you need to be to articulate what is
your story
and number two there is some discipline
involved here
yeah when you were going to work and you
were tired you still had to show up
you still had to do things at your job
you didn't want to do
or you were tired of doing but that was
your job and you were on the clock
and so there is seasons
i guess for every
stay-at-home parent
forever
is
yeah i am exhausted and i got to do
laundry again
and it just never stops and oh good
there's more dishes in this they keep
coming and they can't grow in this sink
right it just never stops
and there's that part too where you just
have to do things that you don't want to
do or you're tired of doing
but to me it feels like there's
something deeper than that
that you thought this was going to be
different or easier or simpler or
it would just work out and it's not and
it's
weighing on you maybe i'm out to lunch
man maybe it's not existential at all
it's just a matter of dude yeah no it's
all that
if you want to clean house have a clean
house but all of a sudden you look up
and it's 10 30 in the morning
have you done a
like uh
have you done like an honest assessment
of how much time you spend on social
media how much time you spend from the
tv how much time you spend
um
emailing folks
like have you done an honest time
assessment
i've
been trying to like i'm not trying to
have you done a honest time
like to me an honest time assessment is
like i want a minute by a minute count
of like how did i spend my time so i've
been like looking for like how do i
track that because if i just have a
piece of paper i'm not gonna like
write down every single second so i've
been thinking about it so no i haven't
actually calculated the times but rosie
can i be honest there's something else
here what's the other what's the other
thing
the other thing is what is it that you
don't want to say out loud say it
um
my child
has
adhd and odd
and i guess just like
sometimes it's such a war zone all day
that it's like
i guess i just feel like i need to treat
myself like
i'm so exhausted like i can't do
anything else
you need some help
is your home chaotic
young
sometimes sometimes it's not
is your marriage okay
yeah
yeah my husband's amazing
has your
child always struggled with that
disconnect
because adhd odd those kind of things
are
generally challenges not always but
generally challenges with disconnection
with relational challenges
i thought we had
a pretty
good connection like all three of us and
then
um
yeah like several months ago i don't
know like almost a year ago
it just seemed like his outrages were
just getting
more and more extreme like we couldn't
connect to him in those moments and so
have you taken him to a good play
therapist to see what's going on
we haven't found a good one we found
terrible ones like we were on a waiting
list for nine months and then we finally
get there and it was just
kind of a waste of time
why was it a waste of time
um
because we just played we didn't do
anything
for like learning skills like that's a
kit
any play therapist for the first three
four or five sessions is just simply
going to play with your kid because
that's how kids communicate through play
that's their language
yeah and if you're a parent and they may
not have done a good job setting it up
or you may be an impatient parent
which is you by the way um
just looking at play therapy can seem
insane
because a good play therapist is going
to try to learn the language of your
child
and learn what stories are they're
trying to connect
to it's hard
yeah you gotta give that some time
yeah
i guess when i say it seems like
a waste of time like
the person kind of just sat back and
like watched the two of us play and like
i just felt like yes yes but you don't
like i guess just you didn't like being
instructions like yes
yes
it's called non-directive play therapy
it's exactly what it is well nobody told
me that because what they're trying to
do what are we doing here they are
trying to see how you engage with your
child
because here's why behavior is a
language
and when your kid has an outburst
they're trying to tell you something and
it's usually you don't see me
or i don't see you seeing me
or i have no boundaries or structure
or you spend so much time looking at a
screen i need you to see me
or even when you're with me you haven't
dealt with your own depression or
anxiety and i've you are with me
physically but you are not with me
spiritually mentally
and kids or
who it could be a thousand different
things
that's what a play therapist does is
just trying to read the the
communication patterns between a parent
and child
and i don't think you liked being
watched like that
it's probably unnerving
and in five or ten minutes you probably
got really bored playing with your kid
is that fair yeah and then
then you wonder
if you can't spend five or ten directed
minutes with your child
it doesn't surprise me that your child
is desperate for connection all over the
place
and so what i want you to not not as a
shame thing
it's just a set of skills
it's just like dude i don't know how to
hang drywall i've tried it's a it's a
mess i gotta learn how to do that if i
ever wanna to build a house
and so that's why you need some skills
you all need to learn new ways to
communicate but if you don't demonstrate
how you communicate then no one can help
you if you like a plumber can't just
like stand on your front yard and be
like well you just need to flush the
toilet and fix this part i got to go in
there and look
and i'm just gonna sit there and flush
the toilet and listen and stuff like
that it's gonna be weird that's what we
gotta do
but it my guess is tell me i'm crazy
you are carrying some sort of shame
baggage that's heavy
or the last 24 months which nobody's
been good at
has just wrecked you
tell me i'm wrong if i'm wrong
i feel like i'm ashamed of my lack of
contribution there you go
and shame is a black hole
and kids get sucked into those things
you get sucked into those things
marriages get sucked into black holes
you sound tired
yeah
not tired like sleepy tired but tired
existentially exhausted
and so here's what here's what's on the
horizon for you
number one is kindergarten
you're gonna have a shift next year if
you choose to put your kid in school
and so you're gonna have an identity
shift you're gonna have a household
shift things are gonna be different so
you may be looking at six more months
seven more months before things shift
again
i want you to see value in rosie the way
i see valiant rosie
and you're worth being well
and you're worth peace
and you're worth laughter and you're
worth a babysitter
and you're worth telling a five-year-old
here's our boundaries
and you're worth learning how to play
with your kid
not being annoyed by them you're worth
not being on your phone all the time
you're worth not comparing yourself to
the other people's houses you go to who
cares forget them
my house is messy but my house is more
fun than yours haha
you have fun that's what i'm saying
people come to my house all the time and
i tell them
y'all are my friends i'm a clean up for
you but we're gonna have a time of your
life
we do clean up
relatively depends on who you are
it sounds like you're in a shame
comparison
spiral
and i would love love love rosie love to
see you
go talk to somebody and say i'm not okay
tired
and i'm ashamed of my lack of
contribution but then when i'm
contributing i'm ashamed that i'm not
spending enough time with my son i'm
ashamed about how my son acts in my
house
i'm ashamed that i can't play 10 minutes
with my kid without getting bored and
then wanting to go do something else
i want you to take an honest time
assessment rosie on how you're spinning
in front of screens now you just been
disconnected
i want you to be honest about learning
some new skills your kid needs that so
here's the question
that you got to ask yourself
this is all the way this is right now
and there's a period at the end of the
sentence
the question you gotta ask yourself is
what are you gonna do tomorrow
what will be different tomorrow than
today
are you asking me now yeah
um what phone call we make tomorrow
well tomorrow i'm going to meet with
another mom who has her son has
developmental disabilities as well so
we're going to be talking about it
together cool so when when you go meet
with that mom
i want you to tell her what you told me
i'm ashamed of my lack of contribution
i don't know how to play with my kid for
more than five minutes without getting
bored can you help me with that
yeah
i want to better engage with my kid
and chances are
your kid feels plugged in then your
kid's brain says now i'm safe
and your kid's brain doesn't sh doesn't
fire off all the signals that are all
over creation
that manifests themselves in all sorts
of different whatever diagnostic
diagnostic labels who want to stick on
stuff
but almost every childhood challenge is
related to connection in some shape form
or fashion relational connection so
people ask me like hey my kids struggle
with anxiety my first thing is fix your
marriage make sure your marriage is
strong and good
the second thing is make sure you're
okay
because kids absorb tension and kids who
struggle with adhd i'm one
generally grow up in homes of that are
got chaos
moms who have extreme stress or moms who
are struggling with identity challenges
who am i where am i
odds i mean similar the kids are
screaming for boundaries help help help
help help
show me boundaries hold boundaries love
me
and it's hard these these aren't
conversations about blame these are
conversations about tools conversations
about
um
strategies conversations about learning
new things and we all can learn new
things
i'm trying to do it every day
i'm proud of you for calling rosie i'm
proud of you for loving that little boy
and
i want you to start loving rosie
be honest for the first time with that
mom tomorrow no showing no performances
no
just say hey i'm not doing okay
start with vulnerability there somebody
you trust
i recommend you call a counselor maybe
get back on that play therapy list and
give it a shot
but start with vulnerability tomorrow
proud of you rosie